serene it's been five years since the
last king of Iron Fist was crowned and a
new tournament is coming up which Tekken
7 oh gosh I am so excited for this game
as a seasoned Tekken veteran who used to
compete in tournaments I'm very excited
for the revival like the proper revival
of a numbered Tekken game so Tekken 7
isn't actually out on console yet we
recently spent a lot of time with an
arcade role of the game which gave us a
really good feel for the game's
mechanics where it's going with Tekken 7
and some of the new characters we
thought we'd share some thoughts and
look head to when it's actually coming
up well my first impressions of the game
I was playing it a little bit the
arcades as well but that machine that
was just so poorly maintained and always
crowded so I kind of gave up for a while
but going back you know and getting
hands-on I was you know quite impressed
especially you know when I started
playing against other players who were
around the same level as me one of the
things that I criticized a lot for
Tekken Tag Tournament 2 was the damage
scaling in combos and moves and I felt
like it was just such a combo heavy game
all about launching started your combo
and there's less room for like
mind-games spacing and decision-making
so you know that's one of the things I
liked about Tekken 7 they seem to have
kind of scaled that back as someone who
doesn't play many Tekken games Edmond
I'm curious to know what you thought
about it after getting hands-on yeah
look it's really interesting the last
Tekken game I really put some time into
was Tekken 5 dog resurrection on the ps3
and so even though I'm sure the Tekken
series has gone through a bunch of
changes coming to Tekken servant it
still just felt like good old Tekken to
me so I didn't really see the new ones
that you were seeing about damage can
because I never got to the point where I
was pulling off 10 hit combos come every
time that some it was familiar enough
for me to sort of pick my favorite
characters and get a really good feel it
just felt like taking I don't know what
else there is to say about it I mean the
thing about Tekken you know versus all
the fighting games is if you're a
newcomer you can come into the game and
press a lot of buttons and still make
things happen take into the seminal mash
game
like yeah and like that's what makes the
kind of fun and exciting for people even
like for people who don't really get
like into the game or Depp might invest
very heavy amounts of time into it it
can still be a fun game to play and I
think that's you know that helps make it
accessible to a lot of people yeah much
more so than straight butter where you
don't need to worry about sort of
commands for special rooms or whatnot
it's just enough right left right let's
talk about some of the new mechanics
there's obviously a new super system
right so it's like rage art or critical
art depending on the translation you
wish to use but basically once your
character reaches like lower health and
the bar slot starts flashing red you can
execute like a one-off move that's
really flashy and in actuality kind of
useless to be honest it's really unsafe
yes it's really unsafe um when it's
happening and it's really unsafe on
block as well and yes it can be blocked
so one of the things like my main grabs
path is this critical art slash rage art
move is that even like if you are not
doing anything and your opponent does it
you can just hit block straightaway as
like they're executing because a little
like flashy cutscene happens as soon as
they initiate it and you can just block
it straight away on like reaction which
makes it kind of useless but I I was
watching a couple matches later on and I
like I think there are very specific
situations in which you can use that
move where it does become a little bit
more useful but other than that like all
the matches like that I watched in the
community that night that we were
playing no one really seems to be using
critical angles so we know there are
bunch of your characters in Tekken 7 we
the the build we played didn't have
Akuma no new feature but what did you
think of some of the new characters did
you get time to use some of those guys I
really like what they've done with the
cost this time around they've like
they've scaled it back they've kind of
trimmed the fat a bit and added a whole
lot of interesting new characters who
all play in really different ways
lucky Chloe who is like the cat the cat
girl who loves Japan so she actually
speaks in like broken English Japanese
accents of English you know she's really
cute
she helped some randoms like cat ear
outfit um you know I thought she was
really fun to watch surprisingly I
thought she would be annoying but she's
actually fun to watch other characters
like Josie who is like the Filipino girl
yeah yeah I thought she had some great
moves you could see the similarities
between some of her moves and bursts
Bruce's moves who was not in this second
there anymore but he was in the previous
game so I feel like they've kind of done
this whole tributes to old characters
through these new characters no Bob
though no not thus far I think like the
Tekken scenes kind of died in the last
few years it's been a while since the
proper Tekken games come out right and
especially in the competitive scene um
taken is just lost so much attention to
Street Fighter and I feel like Tekken 7
is going to be the game that helps get a
lot of that back we'd hope so oh so
there's no confirmed release date for
the PlayStation 4 version of Tekken it
just yet know that there are still there
are continual update to the arcade
that's right all happening if they don't
release Tekken 7 this year it is going
to be like the nail in its coffin right
it's hard are too long if five years is
fine it has been way too long
Harada if you're listening to this
please stop making her be VR games and
get do this for the Tekken community
alright so yeah good overall Tekken good
right yes I'm very hot for this and I'm
really like I'm going into this game
feeling really positive and excited to
see what other people think about it
game over